[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
look who it is is the baddest
[ __ ] I know
we put you on for Joey forgot about you
[ __ ] have been busy [ __ ]
trying to put moves together trying to
write jokes you know me I'm a [ __ ]
dumb [ __ ] but you know me at least I'm
trying I'll know what's wrong with my
[ __ ] head dude Deluxe that's a little
[ __ ] up uncle Joey here I went to the
wheat store today oh [ __ ]
for rhenium as usual [ __ ] around let
you [ __ ] know what's going on
and [ __ ] in my world there's this indica
what is it
this [ __ ] I gotta fix my eyes
guys limitation don't get old because
you lose your vision four years at 2020
I stopped doing coke my [ __ ] eyeballs
went to [ __ ] that's why if you whatever
you don't keep [ __ ] doing it if it
works you understand me and the words of
Sheryl Crow if it makes you happy it
can't be so bad if it makes you happy
well you [ __ ] Nazi let's finish off
this [ __ ] ghost we have left
over from the weekend you know I mix and
match my weeds I can't smoke the same
weed every day so like let's say in the
morning I'll still have my brand
then in the afternoon I'll switch it up
then the next day I'll hit the dirt you
know who said I gotta keep confusing the
[ __ ] mind cuz if not yeah ain't
working
that's what tomorrow today understand
first off let's get some straight
I love waking up in the morning with the
Sun when the sun's out the birds are
chirping and smoking this [ __ ] that
[ __ ] sake the [ __ ] smoke but then
comes about 5:30 the corner of 6th
jointly there has to be a special
[ __ ] number
that's my broker this [ __ ] gorila
gluteal I'll tell you
I picked up about 11 o'clock there was
in the car [ __ ] cement a path more
like a quorum of 12 hang on why these
[ __ ] I came back I like the Sun
Visor
open some Sun girls turn I leave in the
middle of [ __ ] colleges bakes so that
[ __ ] gorilla flu is like [ __ ] crazy
glue once and it's your [ __ ] mind
never snot [ __ ] crazy cool tremendous
spend years the [ __ ] when I did it I
was the man in exam but Joey what's with
the chitty-chat sparked the rest that
[ __ ] ghost up alright alright already
[Music]
see the relaxation of the [ __ ] mutt
[ __ ] that's very important when you're
blowing smoke on [ __ ] like that you
found
nice they might be [ __ ] polka it's a
half a shish kebab stick how to get from
the [ __ ] shits good mob guy what he
gonna do things get bad the other would
listen to getting that roll of papers
you're [ __ ] Adam and even you pop an
apple out of your ass yes sir
hey listen that's how real [ __ ] mug
smokers do it if you don't want these
okey-doke [ __ ] okay we not have
papers we'll get the [ __ ] out of here
that's when you have to go to survival
tips to smoke reefer
tremendous
a little dinner
don't spot tonight that a black horse
maybe do a little protein shaky novel
joy gone I'm a man of many [ __ ]
mysteries and that's it that's it that's
that
we'll take a [ __ ] ghost let's put it
in and then we'll start this [ __ ]
body adjustability
[ __ ] developing this [ __ ] it wasn't
even on the Shelf yet
you gotta go time for the dungeon
together grandpa was just finishing that
[ __ ] understand me This Is It
this is that you know I don't know what
people want people want this this smoke
reefer you see the [ __ ] devil that's
it that's my tunnel your world is and I
hope you'll find I hope your world
beautiful my same nothing bad but listen
at the end of the [ __ ] day I just
want to smoke a bowl and see my [ __ ]
goombazz and that's it move on with my
[ __ ] life I don't need all this
glamour you look like a man of glamour
you [ __ ] I'm saying swingin dick and
given our bubble gum since 1981
straight-up like the [ __ ] savage of
debt
tremendous God is really [ __ ]
shine this light on us now we have the
ability to get together in the after the
look of us just like we want as we get
together smoke a bowl together and then
go in your house and do it the [ __ ] you
gotta do that that's a perfect [ __ ]
world where I come from pretty slowly to
smoke and touch each other I could
squeeze you dead from the screen
tremendous
[ __ ] people walking by looking around
and I came from you looky look straight
[ __ ] I haven't mean why eyes are open
you never let the enemy know you're
looking at him in exactly [ __ ] kids
don't know dick about the date
nice
for [ __ ] get you yesterday they're
addicted doesn't what did you do to
Saturday Sunday and [ __ ] Monday I'm
53 years old getting beat up I don't
know what the [ __ ] I'm doing it's
tremendous it's always a [ __ ] mystery
and that's what you want sometimes in
life a mystery and to get out of your
[ __ ] comfort zone so that's why I
don't you thing and that's it that's
that
smoke sickness let's kill the rest of
this and that's it I don't know if you
know there's some [ __ ] don't let it
go I'm gonna go in I'll put my feet up
and I have some CBD oil never [ __ ] up my
last hopefully the [ __ ] see me deal
that's that we think my phone I told the
[ __ ] about my best said the whole
[ __ ] thing
and that's it I don't know what else to
[ __ ] you that's why I love you people
because we do this nobody judges
we sit here we [ __ ] relax we chitchat
for a few minutes not a TP a beat we
would those people they have to join
their hand the joints burning and
they're telling you the [ __ ]
Declaration of Independence like you
give a [ __ ] I could give a [ __ ]
understand me I don't give a [ __ ] but
I'm smoking
I want to chitchat there's smoke but if
you're [ __ ] kind of [ __ ] sit there
with a chart like a mummy of debt [ __ ]
it then
and let's just smoke and put the [ __ ]
things are don't walk ball because
listen if you're walking on ice you
might as well dance we wait we're no
[ __ ] punk [ __ ] here I'm saying
I ain't no [ __ ] family that's what
I'm trying to tell you
yeah I heard that sport
oh I love it with this [ __ ] reefer
falls out of the canister into the fight
that's that listen that's the best part
my [ __ ] day back and holding my
thought everything else is background
[ __ ] music immersed and that's it
that's that I don't know
this is it no German nobody just their
[ __ ] feelings hurt
this is not we doing here you know I
love you people with all my [ __ ] on
alright
tomorrow's Wednesday where I gotta have
a few things in the daytime but most
importantly the church eight o'clock
tomorrow night little be rocking in Rome
gonna finish those chocolate mushrooms
got some people coming by you follow me
I love you [ __ ] stay back I
would have dick without you you people
are my [ __ ] life line you keep me in
check
you know [ __ ] it's like having a
probation officer memory
let's very shut this [ __ ] horse and
we koala tonight and maybe tomorrow
maybe later you never know Lee's gonna
come by gotta pick up Bert Kreischer you
know the [ __ ] deal
I love you [ __ ] stay black
don't forget about me
don't ever [ __ ] forget about me
[ __ ] all right
love from Texas - I love you [ __ ]
Austin Texas September 15th New York
City September 24th oh you [ __ ]
kidding me
Gotham comedy club are you [ __ ]
kidding me a what listen I'm already in
trainings off who is the luckiest man
American actor Austin and in New York
City back to back that right here I love
you [ __ ] State Park